a united front to mark 70 years of
transatlantic defense
but someone doesn't look happy on parade
president Trump's mood may well have
been soured by this video Canada's Prime
Minister caught
apparently gossiping about him to Boris
Johnson and others
the president hit back at Justin Trudeau
well he's too fast and honestly with
he's a nice guy I find him to be a very
nice guy but you know the truth is that
I told them out on the fact that he's
not paying 2% and I guess he's not very
happy he was referring to the amount of
national income NATO members should
spend on defense already on the naughty
step Canada's Prime Minister was in
damage limitation mode I think people
know that the relationship between
Canada the United States is deep and
goes far beyond the relationship between
Prime Minister and the president
although I will say as you all know we
have a very good and constructive
relationship between me and the
president Britain's Prime Minister
appeared unaware of the viral video
you've been pictured in this buckingham
palace reception with Prime Minister
Trudeau and others apparently having a
joke maybe at mr. Trump's expense do you
not take president Trump seriously
that's that's complete nonsense and I
don't know where that come from
the spat chilled the birthday atmosphere
at this Golf Resort in Watford it came
after rouse yesterday between President
Trump and Frances Emmanuel macron but
there were reasons to celebrate Turkey's
president backed down from a threat to
block a plan for Baltic defences and in
a declaration leaders mentioned China
for the first time saying it poses
challenges and opportunities the NATO
chief sounded buoyant despite the bad
vibe are you not worried that these kind
of public disagreements are undermining
the unity of the Alliance there has been
a disagreements in NATO as long as this
alliance has existed we are 29 different
countries from both sides of the
Atlantic with different history
different geography and different
political parties in power so of course
there are differences at meetings like
this he's normally the warm-up act for
the Alliance's most powerful member not
this time okay so the news
President Trump then seemed to mock the
media and his Canadian counterpart igor
boost or maybe really with nothing more
to say
president Trump headed home clearly this
is one golf course he's not keen to hang
around on Deborah Haines Sky News at the
NATO meeting in Watford